Great job completing Descriptive Statistics. I really hope you've enjoyed
this experience. Having taken this course, you should now know how
to summarize data by measuring its center and its variance.
You should be familiar with how to use Google Spreadsheets to
handle data sets as well as how to visualize data.
And finally, you should have introductory knowledge of probability and how
it can be applied to normalized data. In the final
project, you will conduct an experiment using a deck of cards.
You will sample and describe your own
data using visualizations and descriptive statistics. Now
once you completed the final project, you'll
be ready to move on to Inferential Statistics,
where you will learn how to make predictions using data. There's a link to
this course in the instructor's notes box.
We really look forward to seeing you there.